The eighth common misconception
or the eighth most common misconception
amongst the non-Muslim Islam is why do
Muslims when Islam is against idol
worship why do Muslims they worship the
Cabba the reply to this eighth most
common misconception is misconception is
that no Muslim ever worship the cabba
the cabba is our it's our direction.
Allah says in the Quran in surah bakar
chapter number two verse number 145 that
wherever you are you face in the
direction of the sacred mosque in the
direction of mazjid haram makkah so kaba
is our direction we Muslims believe in
unity suppose if you want to offer salah
some may say let's pray north some may
say let's pray south some may say let's
pray east some may say let's pray west
which direction do you pray. So for
unity Allah has told all the Muslims in
the world face the cabba. The kibla is a
direction. So cabba is our kibla. For
unity we face in the direction. No
Muslim worship the cabba. That's only
direction. And Muslims Alusi in 1154 was
the first person who drew the world map.
And Muslims are the first to drew the
world map. And when they drew the world
map, they drew the south pole on top and
north pole down and Cabba was in the
center. Later on the western ctographers
came and they turned the map upside
down. North pole top, south pole. But
yet the cabba was in the center.
Alhamdulillah. So Islam says wherever
you are if you if you are living in the
north of Caba pray towards the south. If
you live in south of Cabba you pray
towards the north. If you in the east of
Caba pray towards the west if you're on
the west of Cabba pray towards the east.
All Muslims for unity we face the same
direction. When we Muslims go for omrah
of Hajj we do tawa from around the cabba
circumambulation. Why do we do
circumambulation? Because we know every
circle has got one center. WE ARE
TESTIFYING TO Allah that there's only
one God. If you know the sayings of the
second calip of Islamat Omar may Allah
be pleased with him. It's mentioned in
Sai Bkari it's mentioned in Sai Bkari
volume number two in the book of Hajj
had number 595 that had Omar may Allah
be pleased with him. He said pointing at
the black stone that I know that this
stone can neither harm me can neither
benefit me. Just because my prophet
touched it and kissed it, I'm touching
and kissing it. This statement of the
second calip of Islam mentioned in Sai
Bkhari's authentic hadith is sufficient
to prove that no Muslim worship the
Cabba or the Hajas. It can neither
benefit us can neither cause harm to us.
We only kiss it and touch it because the
prophet kissed and touched it. And one
more evidence
at the time of the prophet
there were Sahabas who stood on the
cabba and gave the ada and the call for
prayer. We know bal may Allah be pleased
with him the black slave because his
voice good. Prophet wasallam told him go
on top of the cabba and give the ad and
call for prayer. Now which idol
worshipper will any idol worshipper
stand on the idol he or she worships. So
this proves that we Muslims don't
worship the cabba. Cabba is only the
kibla a direction for us to pray.